You've probably heard it a lot,
right?
The idea of the Holy Family as
refugees.
It's a really powerful image
that connects an ancient story
to our world today.
But is it actually historically
accurate?
Well, that's what we're here to
find out.
Let's peel back the layers.
So we're going to start with a
question that you've almost
certainly heard before.
It's one that takes a 2000 year
old story and puts it right into
today's headlines.
And there it is.
We're Jesus, Mary and Joseph,
refugees.
It sounds like such a simple
question, doesn't it?
But you'll see the answer is,
well, it's complicated.
It forces us to dig into
history, politics, and even what
our words really mean.
And you can see why the parallel
is so strong.
A family fleeing A murderous
tyrant to save their child.
I mean, that resonates with all
of us deeply.
But to really get what was going
on, we need to put away our
modern maps and, you know, pull
out one from the 1st century.
OK, so let's jump back in time
to get to the bottom of our
question.
We first have to understand the
world the Holy Family actually
lived in.
And spoiler alert, it was a very
different place from the world
we know today.
What's really crucial to see
here is the political setup.
By the time Jesus was born, both
Judea and Egypt were firmly
under the control of one single
superpower, the Roman Empire.
So you got to stop thinking of
them as separate countries.
It was more like they were
different states, you know, all
under one big federal
government.
And this chart just spells it
out perfectly.
Today, when we think of
international travel, we're
thinking about passports, visas,
border control, the whole deal.
But back in the 1st century
Roman Empire?
Nope, none of that existed.
Moving from Judea to Egypt was a
lot more like driving from, say,
California to Arizona, than it
was like flying from the US to
Mexico.
So here's the key take away.
Yes, they were leaving the area
controlled by King Herod, but
they were never leaving the
Roman Empire.
They were just moving from one
administrative zone to another,
all under the same Roman
umbrella.
And that brings us to the most
important historical
distinction.
Their flight, and believe me, it
was absolutely perilous, was
technically an act of internal
relocation.
They were moving inside one
single massive empire, and that
little detail becomes a very big
deal when we start looking at
the words we use.
OK, now let's get into the words
themselves, because the specific
terms we throw around today,
they carry a ton of legal and
historical weight, and we really
need to unpack that.
The big concept we need to wrap
our heads around is this
anachronism.
It's basically a fancy word for
when we take a modern idea, like
our very specific legal
definition of a refugee, and we
try to force it onto a pass that
played by a completely different
set of rules.
Just look at this breakdown.
The term refugee isn't just
about running away from danger.
The really critical part is that
it involves crossing a
recognized international border,
and in the modern legal sense,
it requires you to be formally
recognized by another country or
an international group.
Now terms like flight or exile,
sure they describe the act of
leaving, but they don't have
that specific legal status
attached.
Actually, our whole legal system
for what makes someone a refugee
is pretty new.
It was really born out of the
chaos of the world wars in the
20th century.
So back in the Roman world of
the 1st century, this specific
legal category, it just flat out
didn't exist.
Now moving beyond the politics
and the legal definitions, the
story in the Bible itself
presents a situation that's,
well, it's pretty unique.
It doesn't really follow the
usual patterns of people fleeing
danger.
If you look at the narrative,
every single major move they
make, the reason Herod is angry,
the warning to get out of town,
and even the all clear signal to
come back is kicked off by a
direct supernatural message.
Joseph isn't acting on rumors or
political news.
He's following divine
instructions from an Angel in a
dream.
And that really sets their
situation apart.
The story describes a very
specific threat aimed at one
particular child that was
communicated through a personal
warning to one single family.
This is way different from, you
know, a mass exodus of people
fleeing A widespread famine or a
war that's affecting everybody
in their community.
So after all that, looking at
the Roman world, the meaning of
our words, the specifics of the
biblical story, you got to ask,
why does any of this matter?
Why is making this distinction
so important?
What's the big deal?
And let's be crystal clear about
something.
The point of all this is
absolutely not to downplay the
danger they were in.
Fleeing a violent king who wants
to kill your child is a
terrifying life or death
situation, no question about it.
It doesn't matter what label you
put on it.
The goal here is simply
precision.
It's about being careful with
our language so we can get a
clearer, more accurate picture
of their real journey and the
real world.
At the end of the day, it's
about respecting the past for
what it was, not trying to force
it into our modern day boxes.
And that leaves us with this
final, really critical thought.
When we apply our modern labels
to events in the past, what do
we gain in that emotional
connection?
And what crucial details, what
important nuance might we be
losing in historical truth?
It's a powerful reminder that
the words we choose don't just
describe history.
They actively shape how we
understand it and how we decide
to use it today.